When oxygen, heat and fuel combine,
we get fire.
It's basic.
It's primal.
And is the key that unlocked
human progress.
Fire provided
light and heat and protection. With fire
our ancestors could move to new climates
and eat new foods.
Pottery, metallurgy,
chemistry, rapid transportation
and many other technologies
all start with fire.
But imagine if fire had been proprietary.
What if that knowledge hadn't been shared?
What if there had been
just a few keepers of the fire?
What would we be?
My name is Dario Gil
and I'm senior vice president
at IBM and a director of IBM Research.
We are in a landmark moment
now with generative AI
that will shape our society
for generations to come.
In this episode, I'm going to show you
why you need to be your own
AI firestarter,
how to take control of your AI destiny,
to go from being just an AI user
to become an AI value creator.
Chances are you're already an AI user,
even if you don't have a formal
AI initiative or an AI team in place,
it's already in use across your business.
It might be baked into your off the shelf
applications.
It may show up in chat bots, in H.R.
self-service portals, and transcription
services.
These are what we might call
traditional AI.
The focus is on executing discrete tasks,
and usually each instance is trained
individually on its own data
that you have to compile and label.
Now, what makes Generative AI different
is that it is enormously flexible
and not limited to narrow tasks.
Think of it as instead of filling
specific blanks,
it can write the whole document
from scratch to the point of being able
to create or generate
something entirely new.
What makes this possible,
are foundation models.
Foundation models aren’t trained
the same way as traditional AI.
They're trained
using self-supervised learning.
You don't have to manually annotate
a massive amount of data.
You tell them to go read
enormous amounts of text, and they do.
And you end up with a large
but versatile model
with more humanlike language capabilities.
Algorithms use mathematical models
to represent
the relationships
between the words they ingest.
If you give the model
a few words in a prompt,
you can mathematically predict
the likelihood of words in the response.
Instead of needing to build one A.I.
model for each specific task,
you can train one model
and adapt it to many varied
downstream tasks.
So we went from one
task, one model to one model,
many tasks.
Your chat bot and your H.R. self-service
can be built on the same model
as the new app
that will write your marketing emails
and summarize legal documents.
So that's the first critical point.
Ideally,
a model is in the final form of AI.
It's just a foundation you build on.
How you use it is up to you.
When it comes to using AI,
there are basically three modes
of consumption.
The first is embedded AI,
which I already mentioned,
is baked in to off the shelf software.
The software vendor creates the AI
and you put it to use in your business.
Whether it's a writing a system
that can help you strike the right
tone in your email or image
editing software
that can automatically process
your images,
you get access to some great functionality
that can make you more productive,
which we always want.
But the caveat is that what you can buy
so can everybody else. Those capabilities
and productivity opportunities
don't become differentiators.
They set a new higher baseline
for everyone.
The second mode of consumption
is through API calls.
As you develop
custom applications for your business,
they can call out to another company’s
AI service
using that company's models and processes
and then return the results.
This is also a valuable way
of consuming AI,
depending on how cleverly you use the APIs
and the diversity
of AI service providers you use.
You can start to differentiate how you put
AI to work relative to your competitors.
But there are caveats here too.
The first is that, like with software,
the models and services
you tap into are available to everyone.
The second is
that when that API call goes out,
it's connecting to
what looks like a black box.
You don't necessarily know
what's happening on the other end
or the provenance
and governance of the data use,
which can make people nervous
because your business
is still accountable
for the final outcomes.
And a second word of caution
when using someone else's
AI, has to do with the creation
and accrual of value over the long term.
In the past, we've seen a lot of value
extractive business models.
Another company would offer you a service
like this API call
and you get value from that.
But the other company
is also extracting value
from your usage and from your data
accumulating more and more.
How much faster is their value
growing than yours?
Well, you can see it in the stock
prices over time.
There is an imbalance in the relationship,
that can have long term consequences
both for your specific business
and for the overall economy
and progress of technology.
This goes back to the metaphor
I used earlier.
Philosophically, do we as a society
really want just a few keepers of the fire
upon which we are all dependent?
Is that what's best for your individual
business, for your shareholders?
The third model of A.I.
consumption is the platform model.
This is the most comprehensive.
This is how you become your own
AI firestarter.
And no, it doesn't mean doing it alone
and reinventing the AI from scratch
and spending years and millions of dollars
to build your own models.
With a platform
you have all the elements and ingredients
in place to build your own AI solutions.
You have foundation models.
You have tools to improve
and customize models,
and you have processes
to build your own tailored AI solutions.
And importantly, you create
and accrue value
that is unique to your business.
Ultimately, I believe that most businesses
should end up with a mix of all three.
You'll use third party software
with AI embedded.
Sometimes you'll be totally appropriate
to use someone else's AI,
but to fully realize the value of AI
and to differentiate yourself from competitors,
you’ll want a platform approach
to create and own your AI.
Let me just go a bit deeper
on AI value creation,
starting with foundation models.
Foundation models are large scale
deep neural networks trained with
lots of unlabeled data and subsequently
adapted to many downstream tasks.
It may be a broad general model,
or it may be a narrower, deeper model,
but the key is that it is pre-trained
with the expectation
that you can further enhance it
with your own proprietary data.
Like when a new employee
joins your business,
they come in with some general skills
as a foundation and the ability to learn.
The more they learn about your business,
the more they add
institutional knowledge and expertise,
the more value they deliver.
Well, the same is basically true
of our foundation model.
You use your AI platform to tune it
with your specific business data,
your proprietary knowledge and expertise,
and it becomes more expert and
more valuable for your business over time.
And because you're in
control of the platform and the processes
and the data, you accrue ever larger
amount of value over time.
With some of the consumer
AI on the market,
we've already seen some of what happens
when you surrender that control.
You can get bad data
that leads to bad outcomes.
You can get hallucinations, basically an
AI generating very confident
and very incorrect answers.
You can get into some trouble
for inadvertently
using someone else's
rights managed content.
We've even seen proprietary
or sensitive data
being inadvertently
leaked back into the public spaces.
That's why
you need to know how your model is built
and what data was included.
And it's why tight control of
your sensitive data should be prioritized.
Strong
AI governance is absolutely critical.
Yes, now it is the time to jump into AI,
but please
look before you leap in and ensure
that you're investing in a smart, safe,
and sustainable approach
where your business
and your clients and customers
are the primary beneficiaries.
There is, I think, a myth about AI right now,
a basic misunderstanding.
For the general public generative
AI has seemingly come out of nowhere.
A lot of people think that there is
a handful of consumer oriented
AI experiences out there
and that one model is going to win,
or just a few leaders.
I don't think that that's
how it's going to play out.
The future of AI is not about one model,
it's multi-model.
Your business will be using multiple
fine tuned models
to achieve the best results
when applied to specific use cases.
That's why that platform approach
is so important.
And realistically,
the future of AI is not only proprietary.
It will also be powered by open science
and open source.
Proprietary models will play a part.
But so much of what is going to happen in
the future will not happen behind closed doors.
It will play out in plain view with full transparency
and accountability
that open source provides.
The energy in the open source
community is phenomenal.
They are distributed projects, university
projects, corporate efforts, all driving
innovation, producing foundation models
that you can tune and deploy
for your use cases. Hugging Face is
like GitHub for foundation models.
And there are over 325,000 open
source models available
and thousands more being added.
And this is exactly how it should be
for the good of society in the long term.
We don't want just one or a few winners,
a few companies
that can define what AI is and dictate
how it's used.
But that's not going to happen.
What we're going to see
is the democratization of AI.
Okay,
so I've talked about a lot of different
topics, and I basically told you
that you have a lot of work
to do to be great at AI,
and maybe that feels overwhelming,
but really that's not my intention.
My goal is to take down barriers
to participation.
Not put them up.
There is a sense of urgency
and fear about waiting
too long and missing the moment.
That's okay.
I assure you that everybody is in the same
situation, feeling the same emotions.
But I promise that
if instead of rushing into fast
and easy options to check the box and say,
yes, I put AI in the business,
if instead you are thoughtful
and deliberate and strategic
about an AI platform and data management,
and AI governance,
if you become an AI value creator.
You're going to be in a position
to succeed over the long term
and you won't have to start over
every time the wind changes direction.
You may not have all the products
and processes you need today.
You may not have all the skills in place.
That's fine.
If you're not ready to start alone,
find a partner that you can trust
and get to work
so that you can take advantage
of the extraordinary
opportunities that generative
AI will unlock for your business.
Personally, I'm
very excited about this chapter
in technology.
We, all of us together
are going to use the AI to reshape
not just our digital world,
but our physical world.
We are going to use it to help tackle
some of our toughest
social, medical, environmental problems,
and more.
We'll do it through science,
but also by empowering businesses
like yours and mine
to do more, faster and more responsibly.
Whatever things you do,
you're going to get
a power full new tool to help
you do them better.
And its the AI value creators,
that will be
the ones who make the biggest impact.
It is the value creators who will take
the amazing foundational technology
that is generative AI and use it to build
entirely new solutions.
That's why it is our goal
to make AI accessible to everyone.
To put it in your hands
and I can't
wait to see what you will do with it.
Thank you
for watching this episode of AI Academy.
I hope you will join us again as our IBM
experts take you on deeper dives
into everything that a business leader
needs to know about AI.